-Great to see you, bud.
You look great.
Thank you for being here.
And thanks for being on this
coast and doing our show.
I appreciate it because
you're over in San Francisco.
-Exactly. Yeah.
-But you were telling me
that you've been testing out
these driverless cars.
-Yes, yes.
I am a beta tester
for Waymo,
which is Google's car.
You know, a lot of the big
companies have driverless cars,
and they're all over the city.
I mean, they're driving 24/7,
and you can just order them
like an Uber.
-So what is it shaped like?
-It's like a little
sort of electric Jaguar,
and it's got cameras on it
and all these sensors.
And you have an app
and you order it like an Uber,
and it just pulls up,
and you can --
-There's no driver?
-There's no driver.
Your app unlocks the door,
you get in, and you go.
And I've done it
probably a dozen times
and just did it yesterday.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-And you're not scared?
-You know, it's a little weird
at the beginning.
I mean, you --
The first time I got in,
you're sort of thinking, like,
the scene
in "The Fast and Furious."
You know,
when the cars are, like,
dropping out
of the parking lot
and, you know, like, somebody
remotely controlling it.
But, you know, after a while,
it's so normal.
I was in one with my son
the other day,
and we were whispering
because we didn't want
the driver to hear us.
-Yeah.
-But then you realize
there's no driver.
And they're absolutely amazing.
I mean, there are still
some kinks to work out,
but these are gonna be
all over --
-There's some kinks.
-A few.
But, I mean, they've driven
millions of miles
all over San Francisco.
-Will be in every city,
you think?
-I think so...
And people are super excited.
I mean, people get really
kind of freaked out about it.
Like, when we --
when I get out of it,
people gather around
like paparazzi and snap pictures
because they're so excited
to see something coming
out of a driverless car.
-You actually brought us a video
of a ride you took in one.
Thank you for doing this.
Let's go through
what's going on.
Wait. So why even have
the wheel, though?
-Yeah, I know, I know.
-That scares me a little bit.
I don't want to see that.
Oh, no. This is terrible.
-This is it.
I'm in the back seat. Yeah.
-No, no no, no, no, no,
-Yeah. All -- Yeah. All over.
And you can take it
all over the city
anywhere in San Francisco.
-No.
See, if I was designing
this thing --
I'll talk to Google.
We'll figure it out.
If I was designing that, I would
get rid of the whole wheel.
Get rid of the passenger seat.
I don't want to see the seat.
-No. Right. Yeah.
-What does that do for me?
-That's right.
See a wheel? That's frightening.
-Exactly.
-I just want to be in --
-You just want the thing. Right?
-I want to be in, like,
the Las Vegas Sphere almost.
I don't even want
to look out the window.
And I want to be in Paris.
-That's coming.
-That is, right?
-This interview will probably --
In 20 years, people will laugh
and they'll go, "Oh, Jimmy
Fallon said this would never..."
I am saying
it will be the future.
-It is.
-It is the future.
-In 10 years.
-It's happening.
-This -- What you just saw there
will be everywhere.
-I agree with you, but I don't
think the wheel will be there.
-No. Yeah.
I think it's a good idea.
-I think the wheel is a waste
of space, and it freaks me out.
I don't even need
to see the front.
Do you want to see the street?
-No, you don't need to see it.
-I would get scared.
-You can actually have just
a movie in the windshield.
-I don't even want to --
Because I'd be like,
"Aah! Watch out!"
-Yeah.
-Can you --
Can you make suggestions?
-You can't. No.
-That's gonna be a problem
for New Yorkers.
-You can't.
-"Make a left on Madison!
What's wrong with you?!"
Yeah. Yeah.
That's gonna be -- New York's
gonna have a different thing.
-Yeah.
-You have a lot of jobs.
You do a great job
with all of your jobs.
And I was going --
what do you do --
Like, when you're not working,
what do you do
to enjoy yourself?
-You know, one of the things
I do to kind of de-stress --
because, you know,
we all have stressful jobs --
every couple of months
I go and work
in some of
the most stressful places,
which are kitchens
of fine-dining restaurants.
And I'll go work there
for like 3 or 4 days,
and I'll do prep.
You know,
I'll peel tomatoes for hours.
I just did this at a restaurant
called Harbor House
in Northern California.
I've done it at a restaurant
called SingleThread.
-This is --
You just go and prep food?
-For hours.
And just peel tomatoes.
This is kind of a zen...
-And what happens
when you peel the tomatoes?
They just go into a soup?
-It's sliced in half,
and it's a little tomato
on a plate of other things.
Like, people who eat
the food wouldn't know
that somebody spent an hour,
you know, stuffing
shishito peppers or...
-So it gives you a little
appreciation for those things.
You go, "Hey.
Someone did this for an hour."
-And it's really hard work.
But there's something
very centering about it
because it's this
repetitive job,
and it makes me feel like
I'm stepping out of my world
for a few days.
-These are Michelin Star chefs.
Yeah.
-Have you ever cooked
for a Michelin Star chef?
-I have, yeah. I have.
I've cooked
for our friend Daniel Humm.
-Daniel Humm. I love him.
He's --
-He's amazing.
-You cooked for Daniel Humm?
-I made him a sandwich.
It was a sandwich.
-That counts. That counts.
-It counts.
-I would be --
-it counts.
-Questlove knows Daniel, too.
Yeah.
Wait. But what kind of sandwich?
-It was a veggie sandwich.
You know.
-Peanut butter and jelly?
-Just a bunch of veggie stuff.
-Veggies?
-And what'd he think?
-He thought it was pretty good.
Yeah. I've -- You know --
And the thing about cooking
for for Michelin Star chefs
is that people get nervous
to cook for them, right?
Because, I mean, you're cooking
for the greatest chefs
in the world --
like my friend Kyle Connaughton
of SingleThread
or Matt Kammerer
of Harbor House.
These guys are amazing chefs,
but they appreciate
when somebody takes the time
to cook for them.
So actually the pressure
is a little bit --
It comes down a little bit.
-Because no one does it.
-No. You could serve
them Campbell's soup
and, like,
a Velveeta grilled cheese,
and they would
actually be happy.
-Yeah. They would love it. Yeah.
You know, I love --
when you first started
coming on our show --
"How I Built This"
is one of my favorite podcasts.
It's the greatest. It's so fun.
I love what you do there.
You basically talk
to different creators
and you go like, "How did you
start your business?
How did you fail?"
Because everyone
has failure stories
and how to get back up
and survive.
It's just a fascinating --
it's just -- It's so positive.
The message is positive.
It's going on season eight.
-Season eight.
-Congratulations, buddy.
Are you kidding me?
Season eight?
-Yeah, we just launched it.
Yeah. Thank you.
-And "Wow in the World"
is a runaway hit.
Congratulations on this.
This is giant.
"Wow in Space."
You can preorder it now.
I know you're talking
to entrepreneurs,
inventors,
very creative people.
I was thinking,
if you don't mind,
I'd like to maybe sell you
some ideas that I have.
These are major ideas.
-I love it. Yeah.
-I have to do it
in the right order
because some are better
than others.
Alright. Here's one. Alright.
This one's called
cereal milk boosters.
-Alright.
-You could always
change the name.
-Okay. Alright.
-But these are packets
that are the size of
Sweet'N Lows
that are used
in, like, boring cereal
to make them more flavorful
and/or nutritious.
So you can add probiotics
or electrolytes
into a regular bowl
of corn flakes.
You know, just -- You put
the little packet in there.
Water has all these packets.
Why not milk?
What happened to milk?
Milk is the new water.
-Yeah. Right?
-You see what I'm saying?
Do you see this happening?
You can make chocolate cocoa.
Why not make it
a little more nutritious?
-I think --
It's like those packets
that you add to water
for hydration, right?
You just add it
to your breakfast cereal.
-Yes.
-There might be something there.
There might...
-This is a maybe
thumbs-up from...
-I shouldn't have started
with that one
because that was my worst
one, I think. I thought.
But alright.
I'll tell you the other one.
Alright. This one's
called "This Side, That Side."
-Okay.
-Alright.
It's a whole new
a whole new genre of thing
called jumbotron gaming.
-Okay.
-Yeah. You ready for this?
So, basically it uses
the volume of one side
of the stadium versus the volume
of the other side of the stadium
to play a giant two-player game
on the jumbotron
at stadium events.
-Okay. One side, one side.
I got it.
-Yeah. So like --
-Jumbotron.
-Yeah.
Usually there's both teams.
So it's Kansas City
versus the Jets.
The Jets fans are on this side.
Kansas City is on that side.
So on the jumbotron,
you see, like, maybe
a soccer player
about to kick a ball
and you have 10 seconds
to get as loud as you can.
-Okay.
-And the power meter goes up.
You build the energy
for the kicker.
-Yeah.
-Now the other side
gets 10 seconds
to build the energy
to block the kick.
-For the goalie. Oh, I see.
-And you play
an actual video game.
-In the stadium.
While you're waiting...
Yeah.
-Just, like, during a timeout
or something, yeah.
-Yeah, a timeout, at halftime,
or whatever it is.
Like, those jumbotron games
that everyone's...
-That seems very doable.
Like, with the technology
we humans have created now.
-Two microphones.
-I think we can make this work.
-Jumbotron gaming
is the new -- is the future.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can see that. Okay.
-I can see that one, right?
-Keep them coming.
-I thought a slap fight
would be funny.
You know
those cartoon slap fights?
And you just see someone slap
the Kansas City fan -- I just --
Alright.
So that one gets a thumbs-up,
I want to say, from you.
-Yeah, I think so.
-And the other one
got a medium thumb.
Alright.
This is the last one here.
It's a dog toy.
-Alright. Okay.
-That you throw
and you play with your --
I'm a proud owner of...
-A dog, too. Yep.
-I love my dog.
So you play tug-of-war
with your dog
you know, with, like,
those chew toys?
Yeah, those chew-toy things
with two handles on it.
But the fun catch here
is the toy looks like
two pieces of grilled cheese
split in half.
And the dog and the owner are
stretching the cheese
of the sandwich.
-Oh, yeah.
-So it's like
stretchy cheese in the middle.
So it looks like
you're both pulling on
either a slice of pizza
or a grilled cheese.
You're both holding half
of a grilled cheese sandwich.
And it's called
Fetch 'n Stretch.
-Fetch -- That's pretty good.
-Yeah.
-That's pretty good.
-What do you think? So --
Alright. Alright.
Thumbs-up on that one or no?
-I think so.
Yeah, I think
there's something there.
-Alright. Audience?
Cereal milk boosters?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jumbotron gaming.
[ Louder cheers and applause ]
Fetch 'n Stretch?
-Yes.
[ Louder cheers and applause ]
That is so...
-That's it.
It happened right here.
Come on, buddy. Always the best.
Guy Raz, everybody.
"Wow in the World: Wow in Space"
is available for preorder now.